c'est l'organe le mieux protégé il est
hyper bien protégé contre les blessures
bien mais le revers de la médaille c'est
qu'en cas de choc il se cogne contre les
parois il peut gonfler le problème c'est
que les eaux et pas extensible du coup
le cerveau il est comprimé et ça il
n'aime pas ça sa taille diminue avec
l'âge c'est difficile de faire vraiment
la part des choses mais on estime que
c'est en partie lié au vieillissement et
en partie à certaines maladies comme la
maladie d'Alzheimer par exemple on en
utilise pas que 10%. non n'utilise tout
juste on n'utilise pas tout en même
temps il se dessèche quand on a trop bu
quand vous buvez de l'alcool c'est votre
foie qui l'élimine en très grande partie
mais pas uniquement il y a aussi vos
résultats vous urinez plus de liquides
que vous n'en buvez votre corps il va
aller taper dans les stocks d'eau de vos
différents organes et notamment dans
ceux du cerveau qui se dessèchent il
fonctionne à l'envers c'est la partie
droite de votre cerveau qui commande la
partie gauche de votre corps et
inversement c'est chelou mais c'est
comme